ERD no man it's real 92.3 bootleg Capcom
we are chilling right now the man of the
hour his name is Russ man was good
what's up Russ congratulations on this
poor dog I've been seeing all the
footage online selling out shows this is
this your first headlining like big big
tour not so my first headlining tour was
like May it was in Europe actually I saw
I saw that you were overseas like I said
I wanted mean abuser yeah and that was
that was a trip because all that was
sold out like Belgium's at 1,100 people
sold out so that's crazy
that was wide and then I came back to
America and did like a little tent city
run but it was my own headline thing and
all that was sold out I'm is like the
third tour it was like the first like
big right 2016 did you expect all of the
all the selling out yes you did expect
it nice I don't believe yo man I got to
give you props because your work ethic
is crazy like your soundcloud is like
okay you're like the king of SoundCloud
bro thank you thank you I'll take that
how many songs you have on soundcloud
it's a lot and they all got things like
81 81 records yeah which is more songs
than a lot of rappers whole career facts
I have a numerous lines ago straight up
man SES that's actual factual and you've
been rapping because I know you put out
that 10 year anniversary freestyle so is
that the tenth year of you rapping I was
like the 10th year of like this is the
10 T of me like actively pursuing like
really applying yourself yeah that's a
long time I feel like um I know a lot of
emcees and I know a lot of people who
have rapped and tried and given up yeah
what was the the closest you came to
like throwing in the towel and just you
know working at Best Buy I mean that's
the thing I never waver
I feel like doubt is the opposite of you
know
David it's like I never work you know
that mean I just always wanted it like
to happen tomorrow but it's like I never
quitting was never an option that's dope
yeah um ten years you also over a
10-year period I mean from the time you
start saying serious to now you had to
have improved a lot yeah see as a
producer my stuff yeah
that's what I'm saying like at what
point in time did you like say okay you
know what my shit's like pretty dope now
like um when was that figured it out but
like the beats were always better than I
was because I was making well you're a
great and you're great producer me thank
you
I police say that I was making beats
like six years before I got on the mic
side I've had to catch up with myself to
try to sound quick no I didn't matter
no I used to get piece off this outfit
yes they did not really there's this one
produce on soundclick that everyone
would get the beats from some feels like
five pieces
that's crazy some [__] but not like so I
was making beats for six years before I
started making songs so when I started
making songs it was like yo the
production was always bananas like but
like the vocals were not so I didn't
figure out the vocals like til I would
say like 2013 when it like really Curtis
I put out 11 hours before SoundCloud Wow
you know what I'm saying so like it was
on like album number like 706 where I
was like okay I think I think I got it
it's all coming together now yeah yeah
it's all about just finding a range and
finding your pocket like your tone and
everything I'm curious because I am a
hip-hop nerd what is your production
process you use pretty large tools logic
okay I do but I mean like I don't use
logics like stop sounds of course now
I've been downloading
random weirdo [__] for like ten years so
like
and I just use logic as the hub the hub
for sure I know in your music you talk
about your mom a lot you talk about
moving around a lot
why were you I know you moved around we
were 12 yeah yeah yeah but why before
that were you jumping around so odd my
dad's a job yeah he was always it was
like a crazy story with that because you
know my mom went to college but like you
know didn't really do write stuff with
this she was teaching but my dad didn't
go to college so it was always just kind
of like hustling so just you know taking
jobs when he could get them and stuff
like that so we're moving around a lot
yeah we once we got to Atlanta we moved
a couple times then Atlanta but that's
where you know that's why I did like my
formative years that's where you grew up
at yeah yeah yeah hundred percent
now Atlanta itself traditionally we know
Atlanta as you know Young Jeezy and Ti
and that trap wave yeah from the early
2000 but more recently I mean there's
there's different branches of Atlanta
now you got guys like Jarren Benton and
Ritz which do like super lyrical types
[__] and yeah there's the little
yachties and the vibe guys I've idea or
the I have to be sipping on some codeine
to really Bible distance that yo when I
heard little yachty respect to little Y
because I appreciate the way but I
thought to myself I'm oldest [__] but
now but like where do you fit in what
are you fitting because like you have
your own vibe that doesn't necessarily
you know it is just it definitely sounds
a lot different than anything coming out
of Atlanta but where you kind of fit in
and and was it harder because I know a
lot of my friends that don't make track
music in Atlanta yeah they're like yo
it's a lot harder to really pop out here
because our music isn't the thing about
but the thing about thing about just
nowadays you don't need to get popping
in their own backyard first yeah it's
the internet the internet it's like the
internet you're everyone's from
everywhere you don't I'm saying like my
first show wasn't in Atlanta
like my first sold-out show it was not
my first sold-out show is in Belgium
that's so crazy so it's like you know I
figure we're do I fit in and then I fit
in my own lane you know what I'm saying
like I'm trying to like not be trying to
create some new wave and in that it's
just you're just making sure that you
like making [__] I like to you know
listen to in my car like you know which
creates a wave in Atlanta cool I think
that's dope I think that's productive
because as soon as that sounds like you
have a lot of range musically to like
you had record you're snapping as an
emcee and then yeah other records where
you're you know you're doing the same
thing a little bit more in there yeah
more introspective as an emcee who are
your biggest influences that you think
have been produced your style I love I
love you know Drake's Kanye's Jay Cole
I'm like a big like project guy there
are certain projects right that you just
read yeah like so like the warm-up was
banana stand of course the marathon by
nipsey was like shout out to nipsey for
short show though but then you know like
all the stuff like I loved DMX love to
pop just like the inflections they would
do on the hood like their kids
inflection I always everybody's like you
could be so tight on the pen man when
you record those like you have to
inflect in the same DMX in Tubac were
the best for sure but 50 was super dope
estúpido of Eminem what's your favorite
album ever like if someone was like
you're gonna go to jail you don't do
this this fantasy Bobby oh yeah I mean
that's I think that's what I think
that's arguably the greatest album of
all time
it's all good it's like aromatic that
it's not my feet but it's not my
favorite Kanye but it is the best Kanye
it's not Jimmy oh that's interesting
yeah I can admit to it that it's better
than late registration but late
registration is my favorite later where
does college drop out right because
usually people go college drop out
probably third or fourth okay for me
it's it's a yeah it's late registration
then my beautiful
twisted fantasy then either college
dropout where Jesus I really like Jesus
he like he loved it man it's just it and
I did like it at first but it's like wow
fresh yeah [__] French but yeah man
talk about when it comes to your process
creatively for anybody who doesn't know
a lot of your fans know this produce
master mix yeah and rapping you do
everything you're like the one man one
man man seven people in the studio Real
Talk man it's crazy like there's never a
manager selling out shows and you're
getting a lot more poppin you want to
like delegate to anybody on it
not at all because it's just like I feel
that like I feel like I control my sound
so much more than like every other
artist cuz like I'm really the one
mixing it I'm the one engineering I'm
the one taking the high as you know I
mean I'm like really doing everything
that you know that you hear of course
yeah yeah um do you usually have a beat
first in ideas usually always to be
first I can't even think of the time
where I was I mean sometimes I have like
a song idea I want to write like who I
want to make a song about this but I get
still like I make the beat first and
then when like I said your your catalogs
crazy already
yeah it's nuts it's like Tupac [__] yeah
I think we'll talk like like when you're
in the studio to crank out that much
music like some people will do a song a
session three songs a session like if
you're in the same year for eight hours
and how much music you getting done I
mean it depends
I can I can crank out - because my songs
aren't just [__] you know the
questions no no so like I could crank
out two in eight hours
three is like pushing it right by like
maybe to like smash smash I just thought
I'd like to yo Wendy did that label
start calling because you know now if
people don't know your sign shout out to
a was it Sony Columbia alum biet a
Columbia the Lego started called it like
like actively pursuing like I would say
ten months ago ten months ago is when it
got pretty serious yes when they started
like calling calling where there
how many options before you made a
choice where they're seriously on the
table we could have gone anywhere you
could have could just you get a thick
tin to chose we could've gone pretty
much anywhere yeah um who's like um you
know there's a lot of movements that
like like have really come from the
internet in the last two or three years
specifically from SoundCloud like
someone like gez who kind of really
started on soundcloud and and now he's
headlining you know his own arena tour
yeah because anybody's movement recently
that you kind of been inspired by
because man it I feel like it's the best
time to to kind of be yourself in like a
chances for sure for sure yeah I like
chances for sure color notice fire for
surety yeah chances super the super
talented yeah Jake owes another artists
were mentioned Jake oh Jake was another
hardest that produces his own [__] -
yeah yeah a lot of his early [__] was
like all him yeah that's like the warm
to me is one of the sickest projects you
know with cold oh I felt like once he
started to like kind of get comfortable
working with other producers yeah I
think is when like you know but like you
know say like you're just going to
happen I'm gonna get smashes off of like
things I made my
like at that point how do you have you
go away from you no I'm saying like I
feel like you know what friends what my
friends appreciate is that it's really
all me you know what I'm saying like the
sound is really on me some fans of you
know might be like oh you can do
yourself and reassign but it's like the
most important part about all this is
the music and that part I do it all that
stuff and I'm saying so I think I think
it's important to just do what do what
got you there you know the same for
people who are listening right now who
might not necessarily be onto the wave
yeah what are like two or three songs
they should go check out right now I
know my personal paradox I'm gonna drink
with tsunami I love so many frankly um I
love you got a lot of records in our own
I haven't heard a whack Russ record a PG
8 that yeah real shitty hate that
so what a drink worth is definitely my
favorites but what did she go listen to
is um I love so much it's a great song
yeah it's like as far as like melodies
and it's a short I love that I mean you
should listen to losing control is
bananas songwriting I think I think what
they wanted to smash I think pull the
triggers is epic because you're just
playing that for sure
yeah what you're telling someone to
drink with - okay I love that I loved in
Titanic now with being a rap star being
on sold-out tours comes mad [__] man
what you know and I don't know anything
about that and in lovely respectable
females as well but there are them hos
but yeah what has been your craziest
groupie story like someone popping up
the hotel or you know I know things get
crazy man like I've had a homie who like
got to the hotel and like the chick was
like she stashed herself in the back of
the Sprinter when they opened the door
that's my dream you come upstairs cuz
you're dedicated that she's doing anal
tonight yeah kidding yeah looks like a
crazy groupie story you can share um you
know like I'm not even gonna call them
okay what's the crazy overly dedicated
fan who actually take their clothes off
story um you know there was a situation
involved two sisters and a jacuzzi two
sisters in a jacuzzi
yes nice that's what I said
that's that's yo what you need to do is
you need to like just the movies comin
like you got to do the movie or the
that's got to be like a story in a video
or I have to see it I just see like a
cartoon or something come in like yeah
that's dope man uh you got got the label
situation now when is like the first
official I know what they want is the
single yeah yeah yeah which has been
doing real good on YouTube and
SoundCloud for a minute yeah but what is
like the I mean the album plan for the
first official major on major outline my
whole thing is is beause I've been doing
this for so long but I understand
patients and it's like I'm in no rush to
like you get one chance to drop your
debut album and I'm not dropping it
until I have that Drake card at three
fifty cent less
I got a dropper yes it's like you know
that's why we're pushing what they want
we're gonna get what they want plan I'm
going to get who's in control plan who's
reached out have you had any anybody any
of the people who you've looked up to
kind of reach out and like acknowledge
what you're doing I thought like yeah
I've had like peers reach out as far as
I can wrap which is like super cool
because I don't think Dez Shawn Joe and
yoyoyo Gerald is a very uh he don't
reach out to everybody yeah now he shows
you're not and I appreciate that this is
crushing so yes I stole by me yeah a lot
of people switcher saying is there's a
GZ collaboration company I have no idea
you know what I'm saying everything I
organic well yeah you know a lot of
people walkers been showing love like
i'm is cool you know many people i think
i think you know getting love from like
random people is cool but like when a
doctor wants to hear from another doctor
like you're like that's time yet I'm
doing something right yeah because that
you might need a little bit more cuz you
know that they know what goes in for
sure
yes um your production is so ill like I
always wonder what artists that could
handle their own [__] like like once
your [__] starts to really really go
like other rappers gonna be not gonna do
it oh yeah trying to buy some beats
I already happened yeah well that's the
day like I'm a crush to production side
that's always been like I was kind of
like I miss when Kanye was producing
like everybody else's [__] as well as
his own sheen on you know what you know
what I think happened to hip-hop is that
people a lot of you don't realize that
like all rap is so wack now or whatever
but it's like you have to understand
like all the dough producers not a good
gift like Scott stores Dre like just
waves is like just plays don't really
like yeah and that's real [__] yeah and
it's like yo those are the people making
the sound of hip-hop hundred percent
yeah so now it's like you know the young
you know this is it's just a whole
nother way but yeah the only the way but
it's like I'm trying to restore like as
far as production I'm trying to just
restore that like yo this is
oh it's just dope as music like I really
think about like Scott's doors Dre Kanye
just plays like you were running him up
for Sherlock timberland Tim Berlin was
running it Pharrell all these people you
know I'm saying like and now you know
they're just you know they're still
crushing in their own aspect I don't
think you know they're not their focus
maybe yeah the focus is different which
is dope you know I'm saying like but I'm
trying to come through in this play
have you thought about acting you got
like a look yes you know you got crush
I'm fresh the movies you got to look
like I'm so bad at acting which is why I
want to do it cuz like cuz you're bad at
it yeah because it's like challenging
you know I'm saying but like yeah I'm a
clutch move what do you do like I'm
obviously been on the road like what
what I'm assuming you there's a show
your binge-watching or TV shows that
you're into no that's it dangle I'm
always like are you playing Pokemon go
no I don't know okay it's not loud
that's like a crushing a my son's on it
real heavy yeah
people just get made fun of for like
Pokemon but like on the road I know I
know it's a grind like you're drugged
you know that is but I'm always like
doing so much [__] like you know the
shows and then like you know we're doing
radio shit's like the little time in
between I sleep yes straight a hundred
percent
who's sports guy of course well I played
ball high school like weather is jumpers
out here okay so what so I mean being
you you became formidable kind of grew
up in Atlanta yeah what's your team is
exactly I can't imagine it's the hot
dogs I never had like a team in the NBA
I buyer guy okay we were players don't
know a of course like I love they I love
Chris Paul because in North Carolina
Chris Paul went to the high school like
right next to my Metro so I've known
Chris bothers you like 16 vets don't
like my mom taught it dies work we went
to senior faculty game in high school I
mean
and then he went to my favorite college
wait for us I was I'm always massive
Chris Boston so your favorite college is
Wake Forest does that mean you're Tim
Duncan been massive Tim Duncan fan my
mom worked away for us like two years
old like we were getting season tickets
like we were watching like you have the
you know the balls I might end up
getting the whole oh that's ill yeah
that's super so right now all the
players I mean Chris Paul is obviously
on the Clippers but they don't look like
to do anything if you had to pick
between the Cav's and the Warriors which
team are you rocking with because that's
obviously the two teams is like I like
the woods because it was organic you
know they drafted they drafted like it
they cultivated I don't like this whole
no even though they went got Quran which
was but it's like yeah it's like [__]
everyone else was going around just like
creating these fantasy eyes team just
like why not Shaw I mean y'all seen was
already epic but I don't you know I
don't really like that though the whole
it's like not fun cuz now it's like you
know who's going to be in the finals
like yeah yeah yeah NBA is not like the
end in fact the NFL like the team on
paper will be stacked with its football
so like any given somebody someone today
al the best the seven you've knows going
win every time yeah if the lawyers don't
win 10 a roll I don't know it's good
yeah it's gonna be crazy man we'll look
Russ make sure you go pick up the
singles on iTunes right yes what they
want requestion
yeah on the radio yes the videos dope
thank you shout out to me this room man
who does all the big ass Edgar Edgar
someone's gonna steal yo man he's gonna
be producing stuff for a lot of the
right to preside over short oh he's
gonna be doing movies that's what's up
man anything else you want to throw out
there to the people who be able to look
out for anything else I just you know
we're coming and then I'm saying we're
coming we're coming
word up no openers on the tour either no
but as I hate open straight-up sorry
even though the people that let me open
for you I love you all but like I hate
openers might have understood it when I
[__] you
good [__] brother thank you word up
preciate it man
you